airboats boats
propelled by air and wind we're in the
Everglades one of the most beautiful
parts of the country totally appropriate
for the try guys
dirty tour the guys from Amazon's Grand
Tour season 2 have challenged us to get
another wacky race oh holy [ __ ] that's a
big bug
[Music]
previously on the try guys dirty tour we
raked student buggies across the sands
of California
Keith grew a terrible fear Eugene found
out he's a Dark Wizard
I had a miraculous come-from-behind
victory and won the race and I lost
because my duck got away from me so
today where are they Everglades if I now
I hear some British men we tried to
break the water speed record by putting
a jet engine in an amphibious car it's
like a car that lays eggs and now we
challenge you the try guys to go as fast
as possible on water you probably don't
have access to a jet engine or an
amphibious car yeah no [ __ ] Richard
we'll think of something good luck no we
do not have a jet engine but we got a
big fan a lot of big fans across the
world but today just a few big fans on
the back of our boat you're right in the
middle of the Everglades National Park
one of the most interesting areas in the
world a very special Wow so why do we
use airboats another propeller boat
propeller boats not gonna go through
this here's gonna get tangled up none of
that these boats are designed on around
one inch of water it's like a puddle
puddle I'm good
let's get out there let's see what kind
of fun we can there
if there's one silver lining here is
that the dunes are over
sandy Andy is behind me so for today I'm
back to being regular old Zac are you
guys actually putting on life jacket
yeah we gotta be prepared we just want
to be safe Jesse do they need life
jackets I hope not hey this is your
steering over here okay you push forward
so Florida's /no forward is right it's
gonna be a little stiff but it still
move so just remember to push it there
you go
we're gonna ease around that cluster of
trees and come back okay let me pass in
port or starboard and you're gonna go to
your starboard okay which ones that whoa
okay now we just go
[Music]
off the gas that off slow okay when you
lift your foot off of a real quick
motor does a quick change bless the fact
you have no scary now we're whirling
like we're dancing what letter grade
what I get you running up in about the
60s you got to be able to get your
rhythm up and down 60s a fail so no your
books wrong so my book is the c'mon
accounts after master D Everglades rumor
that that's true yeah Eugene's up we
don't need these anymore what come on
all right you're doing you ready
yes okay good there you go boys I feel
at one with this place I also feel
strangely energized in a sort of crazy
way Wow how incredible Thanks so fun did
you come here to turn to fat so I went
into a fast boats slows down it sinks it
was something now we've got to pull
yourself back up on top he's running
about 70 right now I look forward to
serving in your Everglades cavalry good
start
yes when we take over the city for
Gators we can do that wonderful I've
never captained a boat I don't even
think I'm very good at kayaking you move
it steady don't jerk it real hard or
real fast because then you do extreme
moves so that way you do nice steady
moves don't want anything right
got down too slow and then when he
started turning he didn't turn the boat
the boat just kept going further further
so he didn't drift tight enough okay
you're gonna be a little bit above the
65 because you made a couple of big
mistakes I sure did so you pretty much
the same where Fanny is so Jesse you're
also going with with Fanny then yeah
we're gonna stay with that ride for now
I got a blue one on my team we show
y'all how it's done I'm from Florida
we're in Florida let's do this hey kids
there's one speed and that's full
throttle
how fast will be going where we're going
like top speed on this boat here about
4000 4500 fine man I'm not gonna like em
I think I came in a little hot to that
turn yeah you feel really like you
waited too long to let off of it and
when you let off of you let off too much
I think I need to be a little less full
throttle Fulmer a little more nice and
steady men hate to tell you this but I
think Fanny kind of beat you out on
there and so I'm gonna have to give you
like a 59 yeah oh that's that's a floor
2f so you learn on the first trip and
you've seen what your ears work we'll
see how you're doing a second trip okay
[Music]
I started out the strongest in our
practice run and then after that I got
very distracted by how cool this place
is and I might have turned into a bit of
a crazy person as I practice more and
more by the end of it I got a two thumbs
up from captain Jesse
right now I'm the only one who's shown
steady improvement the beard improves
Keith improves scruffy guy
Chomp Chomp Chomp let's go so what is
the importance of the Everglades
Everglades has a very unique ecosystem
but exactly a freshwater river it's not
a swamp water moves about one mile per
day this is also all the water supply
from Key West to West Palm Beach Jesse
tell me about that ring you got this was
custom-made for me about 30 years ago at
one time I used to wrestle alligators
for the shows and movies and stuff like
that
what can we touch a gator sure will let
you hold an alligator how's that let's
turn around show you a baby Gator here
okay you see how I'm holding with my
ring around his neck like that and hold
it tight oh look
put your face closer well he's only got
80 teeth so you might get about a teeny
little piercing down there so I'm sorry
eighty lady he's okay I'm gonna let net
hold him now right take him here we'll
do a change off like this very good like
that okay ah
all right so cold he sounds just like my
dog
oh my god
we've got snakes out here the people
have turned loose there were their pets
and they got loose out there people in
Florida just like have these crazy
[ __ ] pendulum like oh no I can't
happens anymore and they just let it
loosen the ever heard of loose in the
Everglades and it turns around survives
and reproduces oh my goodness I caught
24 of them and the easiest way to just
grab ahold of them and you take a knife
and just cut your throat just feed him
to the alligators so the alligators gets
nice and fat healthy something
yeah real delight at parties huh come
our way up here and we can get in the
sunlight you can see something all right
oh he's gonna come up here and see you
so you get an idea okay so when do we
start running are you kidding me this is
what lives in the Everglades where you
going
[Music]
Eugene what are you doing now how do we
know that he's not about to turn and
attack us what we don't get to have to
watch it to get that answer they like
sweets one of the favorite sweets at the
marshmallow you got that white hat on
that's probably their favorite color
we're getting real close i alligator see
you later alligator oh my god see one of
those guys tomorrow it's race day here
we are having beautiful Everglades we
got a course set up we found a flooded
car dealership to use as our finish line
[Music]
race is divided into four parts number
one a straightaway in which we go as
fast as we can
second we have one big turn it's the
turn we've been practicing the whole
time number three we've just stopped the
boat these boats don't have brakes we're
supposed to then get in the water so we
found some 10 year olds in the pool and
we stole the toys this is tiny get back
into the boat and then floor it over the
finish line that is going first I'm
going last I'm filled with indecision in
doubt this Fanny's ready to party let's
do this
boy
[Applause]
there's really giant right now
let's best turn yet
Matt did he turn the engine off all
right net is trudging through oh no need
for his body to be all the way in it's
only about two P D he can't see because
he moved up all the water it's looking
for a gator you got it that's exactly
what I would try to eat if I was a gator
all right use that cross miss right
[Music]
this is the great parking job she's done
this earlier dead at 303 303
so now that I know what they gotta shoot
again started the race like a gator like
Gator bait oh my god I asked it to rain
starting to rain hoping my strategy can
be to pull up close to the rings and
just fish them out I don't want to get
wet
trying to get a little rain
you do this
Oh as a wide turn for Keith that's his
worst turn yet
alright he's coming in really steady I
think he's looking for them from the
boat well he came in really well though
well he needs to be a little further
this way though he's using a paddle that
that won't work
what are you gonna get into the black no
no he hit the flood here you really
doesn't want to get into the swamp are
you doing getting a walk just get out of
the boat I'll be there push it now he
wants to stay in the boat he does not
want to get wet at all
you can't be afraid to get wet this
bloating
despite Eugene's witchcraft making it
rain only during my run it's stopping
now okay you get a point 306 you had
everything Maiden taste around got into
the pole otherwise you were doing my
Aussie was just too good you know
Everglade says you're gonna get wet one
way or the other so I decide to give you
a little bit from the book I'm not a
witch
I am NOT a witch that's exactly what a
wage would say
the gym looks great too natural on that
though he's taking a real wide berth on
that turn yeah he way right
this is far away as I was
doesn't seem he's got it he's got the
Rings back Oh God
yeah failure
I think there was some sort of
witchcraft in there what do you think
give me an idea
three thirty four to five nine I totally
understand I thought it was Connor no
you made up the difference because you
found a ring real quick right now I'm
potentially gonna be your Duke of
attention ladies Dukes are your number
one at the moment guys I really can't
[ __ ] this up and I want to be Fanny
forever
why else are they asking for a
screwdriver so I do do I just swim it I
guess you'd call it a Fanny movie
[Music]
and not one [ __ ] system you're right
[Music]
that cabin
[Music]
No
guys I try so hard I [ __ ] that turn up
so bad and a shot honey thank you Dad I
don't know man I made a lot of mistakes
out there at 2:36
not deep enough I messed that blot today
but not as much as my friends messed up
feel like I let my state down as less
have home-field advantage captain Jessie
the king of the Everglades was awesome
I'm really sad that I am NOT his
official Duke the beard is the mask the
beard is just a mask to make me feel
more confident than I am
we have a new leader board check it out
I am now tied for second with Eugene if
you would please change my name to Zack
from Tony I would appreciate it but
underneath this big ravishing beard I'm
nothing nothing but it's smooth Fanny
next up Alaska
[Applause]
it's really anyone's game why am i
selling this blanket is wrong
everybody's literally laughing but he is
my fear I'm tired
[Music]
don't go